good morning everyone i'd like to call
the
fiscal committee to order
uh the first item that we have are the
minutes from december 2nd
there was a
a small change that occurred
i believe that was the one and so um
i think so
okay
uh so could i have a motion to accept
the minutes from december 2nd
yeah as corrected um do i have a second
okay uh
senator gaida and uh
representative lieschmann
all those in favor
please raise your hand
opposed
abstain
two
seven to
two abstentions
okay
all right uh the motion passes
the next item are the minutes from
december
17th
fiscal committee meeting
are there any
changes or corrections
who approve okay senator daniel moves to
approve do i have a second
thank you
representative lushman
all the
all those in favor please raise your
hand
opposed
abstentions
the vote is nine in favor
one abstention
and then we have our
night before christmas eve meeting on
december 23rd
are there any changes or corrections
seeing none could i have a motion to
approve to approve senator daniels moves
to approve
senator d'allesandro seconds
all those in favor please raise your
hand
opposed
abstain
three
seven in favor and three abstentions
okay
okay uh now turning to the agenda
we have several items that
have been
taken off the consent calendar
i will go through these now
fs 22007.
fis-22-022
fis-22-22
zero two three
fis-22028
fis-22030
fis22013
okay
fis22
fis22015
fis
three 22-035
fis-22036
three fine
there were so many that i couldn't stand
it
okay
and um
just so that everyone knows
we also have a late item
which is fis22043
and of course we will have to um
vote on that at the end
so
madam chair yes um my my notes indicate
on page four twenty two zero four two
off of consent
is your note different
no i did not have that
did you want it off uh look let's pull
it off and okay and when we get to it we
could just wrap it up if it doesn't need
it
does the senate have any additional
items that they would like to take off
the consent
yes representative or senator roosevelt
thank you madam chair just um 0 3 9
for a quick question
it's fis-039
uh tab
six
okay
uh could i have a motion
to approve
all of the other items that are on the
consent calendar
so moved thank you senator d'alessandro
second by representative edwards
all those in favor
or do i have to call the rule no okay
all those in favor please raise your
hand
ten zero
thank you very much
okay uh the first item off the agenda
is uh 22007
from the department of military affairs
and veterans services
is there someone here that would
oh okay
thank you
mm-hmm
hmm
thank you very much and welcome to the
fiscal committee
oh you need to excuse me you need to
push the button on the mic got it okay
thank you thanks ma'am a for the record
i'm major general david mikulitis the
adjunct general of the new hampshire
national guard department of military
affairs and veteran services
up before you today as a proposal for
approximately 290 000
to be obligated or spent for a child
care initiative
i provided you a handout which
essentially has three pieces of
information first piece of information
is the mission statement of the joint
military task force of which i chair one
of eight subcommittees on the governor's
commission of alcohol and other drugs
through that initiative we try to take
care of service members families in the
veteran community
this specific initiative for service
members and their families
second piece of information within that
handout is a excerpt from a report
from a 2020 analysis of the army
national guard the health of the force
and when you look at that analysis on
the next four pages you will see that
the new hampshire army national guard
ranks 45th
out of 54 in the country in a bad way
for the health of our force
and there are many reasons why
when you look at it the two primary
reasons they call it on that report
is obviously hearing loss
which is predicated on the fact that it
is a army national guard we have a lot
of what's called field artillery
but more importantly
hazardous alcohol misuse
so when you look at the data 7.9 of our
force
has a possibility of
hazardous alcohol misuse
this is a pilot program initiative that
we hope
will provide or reduce stressors to
military families in order to provide
child care and drill weekends for our
service members
the last piece of information in that
handout talks about i think it was my
letter to the fiscal committee
clarifying some of the reasons why
so the governor's commission on balcony
other drugs voted on this initiative i
think last march
and like i said we're one of eight um
sub task force on that commission
um based upon this committee's request
patrick tufts the chair of the
governor's commission of alcohol and
other drugs is also here
and by the way there's also ancillary
benefits of this initiative you know as
we look holistically across our force
you know one of our one of our sort of
um reasons also is diversity and
inclusion
we continue to lose our female
servicemen and our female service women
based on the lack of child care
so for example at the peas air national
guard
our female service
service women composed 29 of our force
when they initially enlist
at the end of a 20-year
20-year career that percentage goes down
to 15 percent
during the process of a 29-year career
our female service women have to make
the decision whether they want to
continue with their service or they want
to raise a family
this is a significant issue for us for
our retention our ability to have a
diverse and inclusive workforce
primarily it's for the stressors
associated with family life
whether it's a single family parent
a single family a parent whether it's a
dual family parent where both parents
serve in the military or whereas their
significant other their spouse as a
second job
so we require three quarters of our
service members come in for that week
and a month because we're a part-time
force this is the reason why
subject to your questions that's all i
have
did you uh want mr tufts to come and say
anything
yes ma'am okay thank you
good morning committee members thank you
general um
as stated my name is patrick tufts i'm
the chair of the governor's commission
on alcohol and other drugs i just want
to add a couple of things to the
general's presentation
this particular investment is part of a
much broader investment in prevention
services a roughly 4.5 million dollar
investment in prevention programs all
across the state of new hampshire that
the governor's commission has made
as part of its expanding our resources
action plan i've left copies on the
table for any of you who haven't seen it
this is the 2001 governor's commission
strategic
plan
this particular program is an important
part of again this broader portfolio of
investments for all the reasons that the
general just stated our service members
endure additional stress and additional
hardships additional
complications in their lives especially
when they're deployed child care
services and access to good child care
services play a critical role in getting
our kids off to a good start and
reducing the stress on the parents
there were questions about the
evidence-based best practices again all
the child care programs in the state of
new hampshire do adhere to
evidence-based best practices this is a
pilot program so we can't bring evidence
in right now as to what the outcomes of
this are but this particular investment
was heavily cooperative with the
prevention task force of the governor's
commission it was co-developed with the
prevention task force and it really has
an emphasis on reducing aces or adverse
childhood experiences and really
addressing the social indicators that we
have to have in place for healthy kids
and healthy families so
while this is a new program to the guard
and a new effort it really is tightly
embedded in our prevention efforts as a
state
and tightly connected to our strategic
plan from the governor's commission so
thank you for your time this morning if
you have any particular questions i'd be
happy to answer
are there
senator d'alessandro
thank you very much madam chair
general
give me an indication of the number of
deployments made by the national guard
let's say over the past 12 months
and how we've dealt with those as they
relate to the child care situation and
the alcohol problem that seems to
emanate from this situation
uh senator i'm saying in the last 12
months we have had probably three to
four hundred soldiers in air been
deployed overseas whether it's uh
southwest border kosovo the middle east
afghanistan um
we're averaging about three to four
hundred soldiers per year um and airmen
activated
for the question yes please follow up
thank you general
i think it's important for all of us to
realize
that
the guard plays a much more significant
role in our military obligations than in
the past
and that these deployments sometimes are
our extended periods of time
uh
it's male and female who gets deployed
so the mother may get deploy the father
made it
and
just
comment on the alcohol problem the
alcohol situation i noticed that was
mentioned
in your narrative
yeah so
thanks senator so again um but we
believe the this is potentially
affecting over 200 of our soldiers uh
and airmen when you look at 7.9 of about
2 800 uniformed service members um
this is somewhat significant i mean when
you see that we're 45th out of 54 um in
the nation we stood up a wellness
division in our organization using
federal resources to bring in a wellness
director a dietitian a personal trainer
a financial counselor and we're trying
to get after the whole holistic sort of
wellness program this is just a piece of
the pie that we're trying to get after
the fact that uh
we have an issue we acknowledge it and
this is where we think we can make a
difference
thank you madam chair thank you general
i appreciate your service and
your commitment a manchester central
graduate graduate of the united states
military academy at west point
and by the way a good greek boy from
manchester um
okay thank you so much
uh representative leitchman you have a
question thanks madam
chair knowing that he's greek i guess
you have the senator's support
you'll need to move the mic up
uh just one question and thanks for
taking my question
how many service members do you think
would take advantage of this program
um senator we're estimating
approximately 200 250 families would
thank you thank you madam
senator rosenwald do you have a question
i do thank you madam chair good morning
um my question's really for mr tufts
um
this seems like a creative solution and
i'm wondering if the governor's
commission has experience from other
states
of using child care as a tool to prevent
substance use
disorders and and more broadly whether
you're looking at
that for other populations in new
hampshire
uh some of the best evidence we've seen
senator is actually from the business
community who's making heavy investments
in child care to strengthen and
reinforce their own workforces i think
this particular program is really
cutting edge i haven't seen it done with
other guard units across the nation but
we're starting to see a
increased understanding that child care
is a critical part of keeping not just
children on the right track but also
keeping the family healthy and
i think that we can continue to look at
you know what the business community is
doing as a real
parallel comparison to um what we're
trying to do here but this this is a new
program and it's relatively innovative i
think it's something that other states
are going to want to copy when they see
us put it in place
uh representative edwards uh thank you
madam chair um
so uh
for the record i i i'm a 33-year army
veteran i've deployed uh i appreciate
the need for this program i i do have
some questions i'd like to just get some
clarity
as i understand that this program is uh
intended to be
uh set up on the weekends it's not a
it's not a seven day program it's a
every weekend program is that true
yes representative
initially it's going to be just a week
and a month or maybe two weeks during
the annual training and training period
so it's just
it's to get after the 70 of our force
that are part time so two weeks annual
training uh week in a month
uh
thank you follow-up
um okay so i
when i was in the army uh we could uh
violate privacy rights uh we we would
have been able to have sort of a by-name
roster of the 7.9 percent
that we think are at risk of
alcohol abuse and then we would be able
to set up this program so that we could
see exactly who was using it because
we would hope that there's some kind of
correlation between those at risk and
those using the program and i'm just
curious since this is meant to be an
evidence-based program the extent to
which you guys are mapping
uh the need to the use
uh
a great question representative based
upon the funding we have to do a
pre-imposed survey of the soldiers and
airmen usually utilizing this program so
that pre-survey would include you know
okay uh you know just a questionnaire
about you know these are the things
we're looking after like is there a
stress in your life is this a in an in
post survey the year later
for in the subsequent years later to go
after the post survey to look at that
data and say did this make an impact or
not this pilot program
go ahead
okay so what i think i heard you say
general uh i don't want to misinterpret
you i i it sounds to me like you're
saying you don't have anything like a by
name list now
of the 7.9 percent who may be considered
abusing alcohol
that's correct that's a hipaa violation
so we don't track we don't distract we
we get the raw data that 7.9
based upon surveys taken during periodic
health assessments as we do our annual
medical training
when those soldiers and service members
are in question on an annual basis
yeah and you know just
the issue it becomes like suicidal
ideations and you know substance abuse
so that's how we
okay okay uh one last one um
are you finding in your data um that
there's a distinction between male and
female propensity to abuse alcohol
i'm hearing that there's a great
retention opportunity for the female
side of the force and i get that i think
that's great i'm just curious if if we
think the female side of the force
is is at much at risk of alcohol abuse
is the male side do you see any
differences uh
so the data tends to say that uh males
age 21 and 25 have a higher propensity
for uh hazardous alcohol misuse i think
it's on one of the pages i handed out if
not i can get you that information
specifically
okay are there any further questions oh
i'm sorry senator gaida
i knew that thank you madam chair
general thank you for coming today can
you provide a metric on like the number
of days
lost
because of
alcohol
misuse or
perhaps parental you know not having a
babysitter at home obviously you must
have absence absence data that you're
tracking
yeah
yes i'll have to get back to you on that
i i think we have that data
thank you i appreciate it
senator daniels thank you
good morning general
uh i have one question
if you could give clarification to the
initial statement that you
said that 7.9 had the possibility
of hazardous
alcohol use
uh to me that's analogous to saying that
20 of the people driving cars have the
possibility of
having an accident it really doesn't
tell me anything
with the word possibility in there i
would say potentially wouldn't 100
percent have the possibility
of hazardous alcohol abuse
senator i would say
based upon annual periodic health
assessments of which our soldiers fill
out a survey for their you know like
do you smoke cigarettes do you chew
tobacco do you drink alcohol on a
frequency of alcohol how often do you
drink alcohol per week or per month
based upon that data 7.9 percent of our
force has indicated that they have a
hazardous alcohol use issue
okay thank you
are there any further questions
okay representative lieschmann
moved item
fis 22007
seconded by senator birdsall
clerk please call the roll
roll call for zero zero seven
representative edwards yes
yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes
senator birdsall
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes madam chair the vote is ten
to zero
uh fis 22007
is approved
uh 10 to zero
i really want to thank you for coming in
this morning as well as thanking all of
our
guard
our guard folks for the work that they
do
and for serving our country as
part-time military people
it's extremely important
so thank you very much and
have a nice cold day
the next item removed is fis 22-022
good morning tammy valencorp cfo for the
department of education
good morning good morning kelly rambo
administrator for the office of
nutrition service and program okay thank
you um
representative edwards you had some
questions on
this
representative edwards you had some
questions on
fis
22 22-022
i uh i apologize i just needed to catch
the general in the hall for a second
um
can can we uh can you give me a few
minutes to come back to this are we able
to know
i will ask a couple of questions while
you know you can i'll give him a little
time thank you to get himself together
um this is the child nutrition program
and
the question i have is this an extension
where everybody
gets meals
yes this year currently the usda has a
waiver for free meals that is set to
expire on june 30th of this year 2022.
and and so these dollars will get us
through the 30th of june on the free and
red on
everyone receiving meals
no oh
okay that's not a good answer
when we did an initial assessment we
were using the state new hampshire first
system and looking at the expenses that
had been spent to date when we looked
into our food and nutrition systems
subsystem we found that we
have not paid out
expenses for november and december
so
these funds that we are accepting in
today will get us through those and into
january we we plan to come back again
next month because we've done in another
analysis
and we will be bringing another item
before you next month
so the federal government is paying
that's not the problem it's
it is
um when we built this budget two years
ago
we did not anticipate covet in the the
changes in the guidance from the federal
government so because they're giving out
we we
are like doubling our reimbursement
requests from the schools
so it's
the federal government will continue to
support this through the 30th of june
we just need to get our
money
out to the town or to the schools yes we
just need to increase our appropriation
so we can fund those reimbursement
requests okay thank you
uh representative edwards uh yes ma'am
um i my notes indicate that uh
i'm supposed to motion to accept this
money i don't i don't see any questions
i have questions on the item after this
23. okay
uh representative or senator daniels
thank you how do you determine the
success
what is the success metric
that you're using to determine the
success of this program
so as you can see um
in the requested action in front of you
that
the increase this year and the free
meals compared to the years before is
highly successful
and that's what we're currently using
the claiming
system
each school claims the amount of meals
that they have served and
this year since the meals are free there
is a significant increase which is why
we are requesting more money additional
money follow-up follow-up
uh does anybody track how much of the
food is thrown away
at this time that is not tracked at the
department of education
and just a couple days ago i read of
some
online complaints from
parents who
posted pictures of the
lunches that schools
that particular school was handing out
and the parents saying that wasn't not
nearly enough so these are why i'm
asking these questions is if we're just
saying success is based upon the number
that we throw out
i'm not sure that that's really the
correct metric because i hear often
about
how much of the food is thrown away by
students and
then this this was new to me that
that some parents were feeling that
their child wasn't getting enough
so the current usda regulations have not
changed as far as meal standards those
are still the same that we have been
following before
and the claiming process is the schools
do not claim meals for which they have
not been served to the students so every
meal that has been claimed is a meal
that has been given
to
to the students so um and again the the
regulations that the usda has put out as
far as the standards are concerned are
are the same that they have been before
they're no different than has been in
the previous years before covid okay and
if i may for our clarification when i
talk about food being thrown away i
wasn't talking about the food that
wasn't served i'm talking about food
that was served that the kids won't eat
that they throw in the trash barrel
yes thank you and
unfortunately at this time the doe does
not collect that data once it goes to
the child out in the cafeteria
are there any further questions
senator gaidan thank you madam chair
can you speak to the numbers of students
that are using this program
year over year
say from 1920 and or 2021 and present
so far in fiscal 22.
so um as stated before the
due to the fact that the meals are free
to all students and not just those
students that fill out the free and redo
application there is a significant
increase
to to the meal program
and that is based off of the waiver for
this year so once the waiver expires we
will go back to using the free and
reduced applications to use determined
eligibility who would receive a free
meal or who wouldn't receive a free meal
in that program
yes
so there's no
financial criteria as far as qualifying
for the free and reduced lunch program
at this time at this time that is
correct that is a usda waiver that has
been put out for this year it was in
place last year and it had an extension
for this year and expires on the 30th of
june
are there any further questions
seeing none uh representative edwards
moves
that we approve
fis22022
seconded by
senator d'alessandro
will the clerk call the roll zero two
two roll call
representative edwards yes
kirk coach yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes senator birdsall
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro
representative umberger yes madam chair
of the vote is 10-0
vote is 10-0
this item is approved
thank you very much ladies appreciate it
okay we now turn to fis22023
uh authorization to accept and expend
350 000 in other funds
through
june 30th
good morning
it's okay good morning i'm a little bit
of a mess this morning patricia tilly
director of public health
okay
um
are there any questions us
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
uh miss tilly for taking my questions i
i didn't realize that this uh program
was in public health are you sitting in
for somebody or or is this your program
is this for 30 i was just uh
just put up here so maybe maybe i don't
know this is for 23.
great so 23 says it's for the
prescription drug affordability board
yep not me
i told you i was imagining i am so glad
other people make mistakes
well it's just it's just that you spend
so much time in that seat
good morning uh thank you for clarifying
that because i was kind of confused in
the back
uh for the record my name is robert
berry i am the department liaison
between the board and the department
i'm happy to take any questions
thank you
thank you madam chair and
mr berry thank you for taking my
questions as as i'm looking at this
uh i'm having a really hard time uh
getting a sense
that
of the extent to which this program is
is cooked and and ready to roll out i i
see that it's meant to rely on 350 000 a
year of user fees
um
and if if you could walk us through
uh the state of collection around those
user fees and
and uh at the rate at which you're going
to expect to begin expending the money
i'm i'm worried about the cash flow
aspect of of this program i'm not seeing
any data in here on that
certainly so the board came into being
on july 1st of 2020.
since then we have been working on
standing it up it's an administratively
attached
board to the department
the
primary purpose of receiving the funds
is so that the board can hire an
executive director to begin really
the process of what the board's purpose
is and i'm not
extremely well versed in the overall
purpose of the board it's more a
question for the board since i'm just a
liaison
but the intent is to start receiving the
funds so that it can begin the process
of hiring the executive director to
fully stand up the board as it moves
forward and fulfills its purpose
you have follow-up i do have a follow-up
so if i
if i heard you
you won't be hiring a director
until after the user fees have begun
being collected
and therefore you do not anticipate a
cash flow problem no the board is not
anticipate a cash flow problem our yeah
cash flow flow problem at this point in
time we believe it it should eventually
be self-funded and uh the big expense is
going to be the executive director at
least in the short term um we're in the
process of
putting forth some legislation that
would move the executive director
position into an unclassified position
and the search
will begin probably sometime in the
spring or early summer
is my guess um it's in other boards
throughout the united states this is a
fairly new concept um finding an
executive director has proven quite
frankly fairly difficult uh the maryland
uh board just uh hired their executive
director after 18 months of existence
and that individual was a an attorney
and a pharmacist so that's a bit of a
unicorn in the uh
uh in the world
um so yes to answer your question though
representative i we do not believe there
will be a cash flow problem
okay follow-up uh thank you madam chair
um
i just lost the question i'm sorry
i think senator guida may have a similar
question to what i was about to ask okay
senator guida you have a question yes
thank you madam chair thank you for your
testimony um
could you put in plain language what the
function of this board is
i will try my best as i'm not a member
of the board
i'm just a liaison but the essential
function of the board is to provide
greater transparency with drug uh
price uh increases or changes
that's the
40 000 foot view of what the board does
there's a greater
in-depth detail involves data collection
involves
developing
spending targets and things like that
i'm not overly sure how that works it's
more of a function of the board
but
yeah the 40 000 foot view is to provide
greater
drug price transparency
are there any other questions oh okay
thank you uh so uh i had heard that the
user fee schedule would need to be
approved uh by
jalcar
and um and that these fees have not yet
been approved so so my question is you
know uh what's your what's your jail car
plan and can you navigate that without
an executive director in place
uh yes so the the statute 126 bb8 sets a
floor for
manufacturer fees which we can begin to
start collecting it's a 500 floor
but beginning monday there's a board
meeting on monday
we are
soliciting public input on
the rules and we anticipate that they
might be in place as early as this
summer
so we will certainly include a fee a
user fee assessment in that in the rules
for jail car approval
thank you
madam chair
uh yes uh representative leitchman
thanks madam chair
and thank you mr barry for
taking a question or two
so as i read the correspondence from the
department
on
page three talk about the assessment
that would raise approximately 350 000
have you
i got the impression you've already
started collecting that too
we have now started collecting that
that's uh we were hoping to get an
account so we could start collecting it
which is why we're here today um
so
uh we have not started uh
sending out invoices uh once we have a
dedicated account to that i believe that
that'll happen soon after but again i
don't want to speak for the board
because i'm i'm not a member of the
board just a liaison but that's my
understanding of the intent
for other questions
so then i look at page two and it talks
about other fees for other
different things such as
pharmacy managers
it looks like that would raise an awful
lot more money than the 350 000 isn't
that correct well right now um we've
identified 500 manufacturers that would
be subject to the 500 fee we're still in
the process
of identifying who else may be subject
to the fee
but that's the best estimate at this
point in time
i guess i have one follow-up chair
so i think
because of other questions that have
previously been raised i did a deep dive
into what this agency is supposed this
new board is supposed to do
and one of the things that happened to
be missing from the correspondence and i
printed it out
and
the representative from auburn touched
on this as far as rules
dash bb colon 6 rule
and it says the adoption of all fees
now the threshold you mentioned that's
the threshold which i assume that would
be put forward to gel car as a base
limit
but again the rule making as referenced
in your
letter which references colon 8
says shall be determined by the adoption
of rules which then you refer to where i
referred to the section i just read so
all fees have to go through rules before
any fees are adopted that's how i read
the statute so i
i'm concerned that we're perhaps moving
a little too quickly because
the
rules committee gelcar has not adopted
or approved any fees i don't believe for
this agency yet so matt i'm sure i think
this item probably should be tabled
until the second time those fees are
been approved by juncker
okay
can i respond to that
yes i'll let you well rsa 126.
i apologize but i think this is
important rsa 126 bba
provides statutory authority to assess a
minimum fee which is what this is based
on
thank you
okay i have a motion to table
from representative leishman
second madam chair i believe that that
uh motion be out of order since uh
representative leishman spoke before
making the tabling motion like
i think according according to rules uh
it should be made by somebody else all
right i'd be glad i have no problem okay
i'll be glad to make that motion
heaven forbid i did something wrong
okay thank you very much
uh
all right i have a motion to table from
uh senator daniels
uh second
by senator gaida
will the clerk call the role
most of the table
representative edwards yes to the motion
to table
uh corporate chess representative earth
yes
representative leishman yes senator
daniels yes senator birdsall
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald no
senator d'alessandro no
representative umberger yes
and i'm sure the vote is eight to the
table the vote is eight to two to table
fis
22.023
the next item is fis-22028
um
senator representative edwards i believe
you had some questions on this i i did
yes
go ahead
oh
excuse me
would you please introduce yourself
good morning my name is ann landry
associate commissioner for population
health for the department of health and
human services thank you
i'm mary calise deputy cfo
thank you man i'm chair um
this this question is going to come out
of left field a little bit and i
apologize you you two may not be the
ones to answer this but um
i'm just curious if we are anticipating
any use of federal funds in the coming
weeks that come into the fiscal
committee
that would address our homeless veteran
population i understand we have about
new hampshire veterans that are are
considered homeless
uh approximately 110 of them or so are
in transitional housing and not in
permanent housing and that leaves
around 10
that
are without any housing resources at all
so
so i i just want to make sure i
understand the priorities of dhhs these
things come to us one at a time as
they're ready to come to us
so uh but i would like to know the the
bigger picture here
is homeless veterans are are they a
priority
and what are we going to do about it
thank you for that question
representative edwards i'm going to
invite um associate commissioner santana
to come up
um good morning i'm chris santaniello um
right now we have a number of priorities
in the council on housing stability um
much of the dollars to end veterans
homelessness comes through the va
and so what i can do is i can follow up
with um
deputy adjutant general um
warren perry to kind of see where some
of that is
and get back to you on that but the
department itself does not fund that it
comes through the um
va directly or hud directly to um
a program in the nashua area and easter
seals
okay uh uh thank you for that um i i i
understand exactly what you're saying
where you say that most of the money
maybe all of the money comes through the
va
but um i'm i'm i'm asking uh if if all
of the money must come through the va do
we have discretion
in the dhhs to uh appropriate or to or
request some of this funding to
address a problem that's not yet been
solved so i will um
not really
so um the federal dollars that come to
the department come through the
continuum of care and those dollars are
have very specific projects um and the
only way you can add to those projects
and that funding is for an additional
product project such as one of the other
items on this the youth demonstration so
that is the only way we can get
additional dollars but i will follow up
also um
with um
warren on the numbers because that was
not the numbers that we had for veteran
homelessness
uh thank you i think they're going to be
doing a new survey next week or the week
after so well
we'll have fresh data yeah the point in
time is um later this month so thank you
thank you for uh
that and if you would uh you'll send
that to um
lba
or janet one of the other but the lba
send it to them
are there further questions on the
afghan resettlement settlement
senator guida thank you madam president
this may or may not be within your
capability to answer but
uh i have received considerable
expressions of concern
for the housing of illegals
coming into the state
i want to know if you're if you
subcontract with housing agencies and
ngos and if you in any way inquire as to
whether or not they are dealing with
the alleged illegal population that's
being brought into the state
thank you for that question senator
guidas um
our
state health our state refugee
resettlement program works with federal
agencies agencies that are contracted by
the federal government specifically for
refugee resettlement so our work and
knowledge regarding anyone who settles
in new hampshire is strictly with the
refugee resettlement program we don't
have
we don't have actually anything to do
with the settlement of immigrants that
come here legally or illegally just
strictly the refugees
so our agencies are federally vetted
have been in business there's nine
national federal agencies that work and
then they have subsets in local
districts and ours have been working
we've been working with ours for over 20
years as a state
before the program even came to dhhs so
highly vetted regulated by the federal
government working simply with the
refugees
you have a follow-up thank you madam
tier can you state categorically
that funds are
not being used by the agencies with
which you contract
to house illegals brought into the state
to my knowledge they are not
i i mean i can only speak with the
knowledge i have which is that they're
federally regulated to resettle
legal refugees to come through the
refugee resettlement program thank you
are there further questions
representative edwards okay this one is
for you
uh thank you so uh on on page two
uh
in the kind of in the middle of the big
paragraph um it talks about the goal of
achieving rapid self-sufficiency
and then it goes on to read to that end
refugee support services funding
provides job development and placement
employment assessment
orientation to the american workforce
education training and referral services
employer supports and job maintenance i
believe
so so i i happen to be extremely
familiar with the
afghani culture
and i'd like to know if
these education programs these training
programs particularly as a result or
is dealing with employment if um there's
an anticipation to segregate the male
and female populations until they can
get assimilated into american society
generally afghani men
are
i don't want to go too far but i will
say the afghani men
tend to have
a 18th 17th century view of women
and training them in the same setting
can be extremely problematic and
inadequate to bring
the afghani women into
our culture rapidly so so would you tell
me if there's any anticipation to
segregate by gender
for these training classes
thank you representative edwards
um
in discussing with our director of the
refugee resultant program
about this question ahead of time so
traditionally they are trained together
males and females in the refugee
resettlement program with the exception
of specific programs where there is a
health mental health or a cultural
issue or cultural historical piece that
you just mentioned so i think with the
agencies who have are the experts in
this i believe it's at their discretion
to determine which training programs or
which populations would need to be
segregated based on the cultural
differences in that society
so there are set ones where the genders
are separated as we would think with
physical and mental health and
and um situations like that and then
where there's a cultural difference so i
can't answer your question for sure
regarding that specific question with
job training with the afghans but it is
in
their purview and their expertise to
segregate appropriately when necessary
are there any further
questions let's see
yes representative earth
thank you madam chair um thank you for
your written responses they were
fantastic
and just to summarize my own benefit
is it fair to summarize that private
agencies have sole discretion in
choosing to resettle refugees in new
hampshire
and their consideration need not be
given to the costs that resettlement may
have in the community
thank you representative
so they
i'm not sure it's so
so black and white in either or they've
been working with these communities for
over 20 years in the state of new
hampshire mary probably might have a
more exact date but over 20 years
and they do this nationally
so they do work with the communities
there's a refugee advisory council that
participates in understanding what the
municipalities can handle as far as
the um cultural competencies within the
community within the school systems
within municipal municipalities excuse
me
so it's not so much that they can say
nowhere yes it's they work together and
they partner and then they provide
recommendations for what the state can
handle and our state generally
resettles a very very low number
relatives to the rest of the country
given that we are a small population of
rural state small urban areas
so it's very much done in partnership in
that way and the communities where the
majority of the
refugees resettle
are participate in this advisory board
and then it's also a conversation with
the governor's office as well before
those recommendations are made so it's
very much done in partnership it's not
a forceful situation
thank you
are there any further questions
seeing none could i have a motion to
approve
senator d'allesandro moves to approve
seconded by senator rosenwald
would the clerk please call the roll
roll on zero two eight representative
edwards
no
chess representative earth yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes
senator birdsall
senator gaida no
senator rosenwald yes
senator
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
madam chair of the voters
the vote being eight to two fis-22028
is approved
okay
we now go to fis-22
you sure you don't want to talk about
refugees as well
i think the associate commissioner
handled that well thank you yes she did
she did very well
okay if you would reintroduce yourself
patricia tilly director of the division
of public health services in the
department of health and human services
okay representative erf you had some
questions
yes i just have one
confirming question if you will
can you confirm that the opioid crisis
dashboards are anticipated to be
available early february this year that
is my our understanding we are very
close to the end and um we anticipate
that they will be ready by february in
february super you know let us know when
so we will
thank you
representative senator rosenwald thank
you madam chair good morning on page two
the narrative um in number four says
enhance the prescription drug monitoring
system
but i couldn't see elsewhere in the
narrative what those enhancements are so
could you please tell us what's being
done to the pbdmv
sure thank you for that question senator
so um in general the paragraph that
you're referring to in number four is
the overall work of od2a which is the
acronym for this particular funding
source opioid data to action so that's
what ota od2a stands for and in general
we provide support to the prescription
drug monitoring program for some of
their data initiatives to support that
um
but with these particular funds there is
nothing that we are using in this fund
set of this carry forward to do
additional work for the prescription
drug monitoring program
are there any further questions
senator guida thank you madam chair so
safe to say that these funds will in no
way
increase the or decrease the privacy
constraints currently on the pdmp
program that is correct senator thank
you
any further questions
seeing none could i have a motion
thank you senator d'alessandro seconded
by senator birdsall
will the clerk please call the roll roll
on zero three zero representative
edwards yes
clerk votes yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes senator birdsall
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro
representative umberger yes
madam chair the vote is ten to zero
the vote of ten to zero
fis-2230
is approved
okay now we turn to fis-22-01
good morning
for the record my name is karen hebert i
don't is your microphone on
i think it is okay it needs to be closer
thank you
my name is karen hebert i am the
director of the division of economic and
housing stability for the department of
health and human services
mary police deputy cfo okay thank you
uh representative leishman i believe you
have a question uh thank you madam chair
thanks for taking my question
uh
we all and we just spoke about the
homeless issue with veterans and i heard
yesterday from a representative in
manchester that it's just getting worse
as hundreds and hundreds of homeless
people
and i noticed
one of course this is a very small
request but
on page seven
in the middle of the supporting
documentation it talks about
the recipient must match all grants and
funds and there's
an exemption above but the box below is
checked
so where is the where the recipients
going to get that matching
grant money the batch for that is built
into the contract that we had now have
with plymouth state university
so the vendor does provide that match
and just one further question if i could
madam share yes please thanks
so i turned back and looked into the
dashboard as far as the homelessness
issue and the amount of grants
and it's like the third page from the
back and there's a little
chart
with i think the smallest font i've ever
seen but within that
it mentions a number of
homeless providers
and it still shows a large amount of
money unencumbered is that just because
of where we are
in the year or are the reasons why that
homeless money is being withheld
so i wouldn't say that it's being
withheld but because of a number of
requirements
from the housing and urban development
agency
there are several phases to the
distribution of funds and having to make
frequent amendments to our contracts
which have to be approved as i'm sure
you know by governor and council so
those amendments do take a long time and
often the amendments are needed because
we don't have the confirmed award
amounts from hud yet to move forward
with them so there's a little bit of a
a balance if you will
thank you and thank you madam chair
senator rosenwald thank you madam chair
has the department made any
um changes to shelter rates
since the budget was signed in june
we have not made changes to shelter
rates uh since then but we are certainly
in discussions about that now
yes so uh i believe this committee was
told that the department would
come forward
with a plan to do that by last september
um
here it is
january
when
when are we going to see that
if you would allow me to look into that
information and get back to you with an
answer i'd be more than happy to to do
so and
unless
thank you
um chris antonella for the record there
is actually as you are aware
um we can only distribute dollars based
on our budget there is legislation
actually um and if you i cannot remember
the actual 415 415 that would actually
look to add dollars to the department's
budget this year um directly for
shelters
senate bill 14. thank you thank you
move the item
oh i'm sorry
she can't see him through that chair no
that's that's not the problem it was the
answer that confused me uh senator guido
thank you madam chair does the
department have any estimate of the
number of homeless youth that we have
across the state
that is one of the reasons why we're
moving forward with this demonstration
project we have
understand that their youth typically
don't want to be found so it's difficult
to count them
the last time we did a point in time
count was january of last year where we
were able to identify 46
in the state and that is pretty much
picked from the street
there are there's other data that the
department of education has i understand
which is quite different but i i don't
know the criteria or methods of
collecting that data
thank you yeah it would probably be a
good idea if you talk to doe
because i
i know what they do is
through the guidance counselors the
principles and all of those kinds of
things
they
that's how they're obtaining that
information so
and
when you mention the term 46 i
i said to representative emmerich that i
have 46 just in the town of conway so i
mean that number is
you know
i wouldn't ever use that number
okay that's just my
comment
so somebody had a question yes uh
represent edwards uh uh thank you uh
madam chair um so
i'm i'm just kind of curious about the
practical implications of where this
program is going to make sure
our youth or i think they say ute in
new jersey but
that our youths are taken care of i
imagine it's a little bit like chain
migration if you have a say a 15 year
old
then it makes sense that the parents to
the extent they're around would also
receive the the benefit of of of a place
to stay
and i'm just curious how far that chain
migration might go would it include
grandparents would it include aunts and
uncles i i mean once you get
one person taken care of i'm just
curious how big a tail a support tail
we're anticipating
thank you very much so this is really
some of the underlying purpose for this
particular
project is to really to develop that
community plan that is subject to hud's
approval but the idea is to really
identify uh not just identify the count
the number of youth that are being
affected
but what are the circumstances
holistically around
that we want the youth action board that
is going to be created by
the grant to
identify that plan moving forward if hud
approves the plan then we will be
eligible for further federal funding to
implement that plan
so there's a lot of this information
that
has yet to be discovered but that is the
purpose of the project
thank you
okay uh
are
i guess i didn't get a real good answer
to
senator rosenwald's question
about
when
we're going to get some kind of report
and and
so
we can provide you with what we are
reimbursing now today to shelters the
department at this point does not have
additional
funds to to pass on to shelters we had
there was a program through gopher this
past
that ended in december where shelters
could apply
for
federal dollars through gopher to cover
any uncovered covet related costs there
is a senate bill that would look to add
up to nine million dollars to the
department to directly reimburse
shelters but aside from that we don't
have additional dollars in our budget
senator roosevelt thank you so
i think we learned that the cost of a
shelter bed was 47
a day
and the state is reimbursing eight
dollars a day
there was a plan last year to take it to
twenty dollars a day
um and that
it didn't it didn't pass the budget
budget but the department told us they
would have come here with a
plan in august or september and
it's now january but we don't have i
guess the the
i believe um if i'm correct in that we
were going to apply for funding through
gopher
for that and instead of money to go
directly to shelters they are using the
shelter um funds that they did give to
shelters and that was about three
million dollars so we're continuing to
look at all of the resources and then
one of those resources is that senate
bill
yes you may thank you so did the
department ask gopher
for the amount of money it needed to to
pay a reasonable reimbursement rate and
gopher
didn't come through after the
legislature didn't it's it's not are we
what we did is we provided gopher um
through the council on housing stability
a number of strategies um to assist with
ending homelessness um and and
supporting the shelters one of those was
for shelter dollars and that was what
was given um with that one-time funding
thank you okay
i think that what senator rosenwald and
the rest of us are looking for is a plan
even though you don't have the money
okay that's immaterial
what we're looking for is
a plan yep
am i correct so the account
yeah so the council on housing stability
which um includes the department did
create a three-year strategic plan that
includes some of this so i will send
that to the full um committee
okay as long as long as it shows us
today we're paying eight dollars
we're looking to pay
30 yep
correct yeah whatever
thank you because
obviously we are all concerned about
homelessness
especially when it was seven degrees
below zero
in uh north conway this morning um and i
think that uh
we just we just need to get our yeah i
have hands around i totally agree thank
you okay so you will send that to the
lba all right thank you
all right now uh
representative leishman did you have a
motion
uh sure match here move the item
all right do i have a second second by
senator d'alessandro
will the clerk call the roll
they call zero one three representative
edwards
yes
clerk yes representative yes
representative leishman uh yes
senator daniels yes
senator birdsall
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro
representative umberger yes madam
the vote is 10 to 0 fis22013
is approved
now
move to tab six
and it's fis22014
representative er you had some questions
on this
yes i got to find them thank you chair
no problem
you're all set yep
given the focus on it we need to please
we need to
i'm yeah no i
i'm not all set
thank you would you please introduce
yourselves for the record good morning
lori shibanet commissioner of health and
human services
good morning henry littman medicaid
director
okay now we can try that representative
thank you madam chair
given the focus on a community-based
care model
with expectation of lowered expense
will the review be looking at how to
coordinate the organizations working in
this space
and how to fill the need for employees
to work within this model
so the intent of this money is to take
on an evaluation of our current medicaid
model we've had this model since 2015-13
and we've never really done a review on
is it fulfilling the need that we
originally intended it to is it saving
us money is it serving our beneficiaries
correctly and medicaid models have
evolved over the last 10 years
there are many different models out now
the intent of this money is to look at
our model
and answer those questions and determine
whether this is the right model
for the citizens of new hampshire is the
current medicaid model the right model
for the citizens of new hampshire now
there are several models that are
community-based care um
there are acos ccos
health homes all of those different
models
yeah i think that the plan is is if if
the determination is made that there are
other models that would fit better for
new hampshire that we would look at
those community-based models but the
first step is to do an assessment of our
current model and this is the first step
thank you
are there further quests senator guida
thank you madam chair thank you
commissioner
uh director so
uh a third party vendor will this be a
sole source contract or will be put out
to
a competitive bid
it will be put out to competitive bid
thank you
are there further questions
seeing none could i have a motion to
accept
senator d'alessandro moves to accept
second seconded by senator gaida
okay roll call on 0-1-4 representative
edwards yes
yes
representative
senator daniels yes
senator birdsall
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro
representative
yes
madam chair the vote is 10-0
the motion is approved on a vote of 10
to 0 22 0 1 4.
yeah
okay
fis22015
this is uh
spending some arpa money
would you mind introducing yourselves
please sure lori shibanat commissioner
of health and human services
and i'm katya fox director of the
division for behavioral health
okay
uh
are there questions
okay let's start let's start with
representative edwards uh thank you
madam chair uh thank you commissioner
miss fox good seeing you again
i
uh i i think my my first question uh
really is about precedent
uh and we had asked mr uh arlinghaus is
is he in the room i don't think he's oh
there he is
um
we had asked uh him
if there's any precedent for the state
to provide
money to a private uh enterprise
for the for purposes similar to this i i
i would like to know if we're setting
precedent or if we have precedent that
we're following um
not not to this scale last year we uh i
think we
set aside about a 1.5 million for
recovery housing updates renovations
things like that within our state and
give it gave out grants to those
organizations to update their physical
plants
we also um with our nursing homes in
order to in um
alleviate uh the situation
i can't even hear myself so
um so um to alleviate the situation that
we had with our emergency departments
and with our hospital systems
we did provide
financing
of 45 000
a bed to nursing facilities and that was
agnostic to whether they were private or
non-profit agencies
i want to i want to ask over your
shoulders if mr arlingham has anything
further on the on the question
um no i i looked we asked around in the
department and in particular joe
and then also mike connor who most you
know has been
with us for
47 or eight years and nobody remembered
anything there's some vague thought that
there might have been a dental clinic
a very long time ago in
conway or somewhere up north that
something was tamworth
pamworth um
but
we couldn't find any any record of it
but um
you know we don't know of anything but
that doesn't mean there's not a first
time for everything
uh mr rolling house commissioner can i
ask a quick question
the um
what is a housing finance
board
that works with
low-income housing don't they provide
money to
commercial people that are constructing
these homes
for the benefit of low income
it's a it's a good question i don't i
don't i don't know about that but it's
not an item that the state has been
participating in before obviously the
bfa does things like this where they
give we give the money to the bfa and
they carry it out so
i mean so it's
it may not be direct
you know managed by the state but there
are other entities within the state that
use our money to
do things so actually um i we were just
reminded um that the state did invest i
believe the legislature directed us
to provide
franklin regional hospital
funding for their uh designated
receiving facility so it actually was in
the terms of a loan at that point in
time
but it was a legislative action that
directed the department to do that
okay thank you
more questions
i'll give i'll give you three and then
we'll
just this may be my only other one uh
but um i i know uh that we've received
communications uh back channel from dhhs
talking about how the state benefits
from this and as i as i read the public
facing document
it shows how hca benefits but it isn't
really clear in the write-up how the
state benefits and and i know that we do
but i i just would like it in the public
record
so uh i i think you know the benefit
is is quite obvious we've had an er
boarding crisis for 10 years
we have invested significantly in the
community and in the crisis end of
things
we have uh you know
in addition to investing in the
community which we have substantially
for the last four years and in the
crisis component
rapid response mobile crisis teams
the third prong to that
system is inpatient beds
our our system have been has been
running at 100 capacity 100 of the time
for 10 years hospital systems health
systems are not meant to do that
so
this project for a capital with that
capital defrayment
brings on an additional
new beds 38 new beds so the hospital
itself that hca is building is a 96 bed
hospital
the total
they will be closing the their
behavioral health units in the other
hospitals that they own in new hampshire
and moving those beds into this one
facility so the total new beds are 38
beds 20 in adult six in geriatric and 12
in adolescent
so that is expected to have a direct
impact on our wait list when you look at
our wait list
you may see 10 or 20 adults waiting on
our wait list on any given day what you
don't see
is that the actual number of er borders
for psychiatric care are is at least two
times that the wait list you see is the
involuntary wait list you don't see the
voluntary wait list where people are
voluntary waiting for voluntary bets
so the the the great thing about the
health the health care facility that hca
has agreed to build is that they will
the bet adult beds will be duly
certified
they will be both for involuntary and
voluntary they are also agreeing to run
some subspecialty
programs such as eating disorder clinics
partial hospitalization
a 12-bed youth facility for youth age 12
to 16. so the health that the state
benefits by
using arpa money
for infrastructure build it's one-time
payment for an infrastructure build and
investing in the infrastructure of our
mental health system which is what you
know and i understand that this is
coming fast for 10 years we've had an er
crisis and we're basically fixing it in
two and it it you know the projects are
coming very quickly
but i think the time time is of the
essence and we have the opportunity to
use our funds for this type of
infrastructure investment
follow-up okay and so my follow-up i
think that was an excellent answer i
just wanted it on the record so that the
public knows why we're spending this
money uh the the the the other question
i think we need to tell the public is
why hca why why
isn't there another
provider out there that we should be
putting this 15 million dollars into
their infrastructure so at the you know
at the same time that we offered the 45
000 for nursing home beds we also
offered 200 000
per bed for a hospital to convert their
beds to a drf and although there were
interest there was interest no one has
been able to execute that uh any beds
for for con
for increasing drf beds across the state
there will be a second
uh request coming forward this is
request one to build a 96 bed hospital
there will be a second request coming
for a 15 million dollar defragment to
build a second
hospital in new hampshire
pretty much the same size by another
vendor those two vendors
one um
local
non nonprofit in new hampshire and hca
who has a very strong who has very
strong community ties in the seacoast
region
was the second they are two entities
that are ready willing and able to build
these we have not had
any other health system even approach us
about converting
beds
to involuntary beds besides the two
entities that are offering to build
hospitals
thank you
representative leishman did you have a
question
uh thanks madam chair i have a couple
but i'll go through the chair of course
thank you commissioner and uh for coming
to see us
peter you've got to move
mike closer
we'll do it that way
thanks
so it's certainly there's none of us
that would disagree there's a need here
i mean we've heard that and we know that
by saying this is moving awful fast i
guess could be an understatement because
i
recently saw an in-depth uh article that
was written just last week
and
hca refused to comment to the reporter
and what was going on and
said that he would not
provide any information
at this time and decline to say
when they would
it seems like something like this you'd
want to get the information out there
that this is moving forward the
community of epping
is in favor of it but i reached out to
one of our colleagues from epping who's
actually serves on the planning board
and nobody has come to epping to discuss
this with a planning board and yet
it says according to a lot of the
documentation that we've received that
this facility will be up and running
next year so i wonder if you could
comment on that
why is some of the secret and stuff or
why epping is being mentioned is where
it's going and yet apparently the folks
in epping haven't heard from hca so i we
have the ceo of portsmouth general
hospital here if you would like him to
come up um and
give you information around hca in their
process
would that be appropriate it's up to the
chair yeah that would be fine dean
carrucci is here from portsmouth
good morning good morning uh for the
record dean carrucci chief executive
officer at portsmouth regional hospital
so in terms of the news article we just
didn't feel it would be right to comment
at this time having not gone through
this process
and didn't want to get ahead of this
committee so that was the only reason
for that
hopefully within your materials you can
see all the details that we've laid out
for the plan
in terms of epping it is one location
we're considering
we have a few that are right along 101
that is centrally located between what
we view as the population centers
in the state of new hampshire meaning
manchester i-93 corridor and the 995 for
the seacoast region
so we have not gone to planning board
yet because we did not want to waste
folks time until we had locked down
which piece made the most sense
well just one further question madam
chair
please go ahead thanks
so in some of the information that we
just received
considerations would have to be given
for like property tax breaks so you
would be looking for the community that
you would be locating in to give like
property tax relief is that how i
understand your documents
uh those are probably original documents
that you have
we do not plan to pursue property tax
breaks on this project
uh if i could manage you i'm just
confused because we just got these
documents last week
so there's been a change since last week
that's correct
uh thank you madam chair
are there any further questions yes
senator rosenwald thank you madam chair
i have a few questions if i could
they're
focused on
the fiscal impact of this project
when we met earlier this morning
commissioner
when you presented to the senate members
we were told by the
medicaid director that when this
hospital is fully
operational
the non-federal cost
increase to medicaid would be about nine
and a half million dollars a year so
in total about almost 20 million dollars
a year
how what percentage of the
patient bed days
are we expecting
will be
filled by medicaid enrollees i'm going
to have henry come up so he did the
calculations thank you
thanks dean
the record again henry litman medicaid
director thank you for the question
um
senator um
the
in the startup year um
it was 1195
admissions for medicaid which is a
little over 40 i believe 40.
and um
the
adult has 236 admissions
i think in terms of
the percentages in that same
neighborhood
the startup operations as i understand
the
statistics from um
portsmouth's pro forma
that
you know they're beginning expecting a
the first year to be a startup and then
ultimately you know they expect an
average daily census of somewhat less
than the full um
that complement of 96 as they're
beginning the startup but ultimately
that's a startup is about 73 of full adc
and that so there's another
20 27 growth i think in the admissions
that ultimately might be seen
um
when they're at full um operational
status
thank you good follow-up so
commissioner you also told us that the
department
expects there will be savings to the
counties
in corrections and
the new hampshire department of
corrections
do you know or can you tell us if
those entities have
been able to calculate
savings that they project
so
when when i talk about savings in both
county jails and the doc and
in a variety of other areas that is more
of a law the long-term goal as we build
out our system what we've talked about
is that the acute care side of
psychiatric care
which is why we filed the imd waiver was
to attract
private entities to come and provide
acute care in new hampshire so this is
one example and there will be a second
example that will leave new hampshire
hospital
to provide care to those very
chronically ill those those people that
have a hundred admissions to psychiatric
hospitals um in their lifetime and
they're in and out our doors all the
time we're expecting to still serve that
population at new hampshire hospital the
forensic population the justice involved
including the dozens and dozens of
mentally ill people that we have
residing incarcerated in our county
jails they many of them belong in a
clinical environment not in a clinical
environment like portsmouth hospital but
in a clinical environment like new
hampshire hospital so
there are several more steps to the
build out of the system before we get
there senator
so i have not been able to quantify what
that overall savings would be to
the county system or the doc system or
any of the other systems including
homelessness all of those other systems
that it could impact
thank you one more yes thank you so if
if 40
of
the
patients will be
projected to be on medicaid
then up to
60 percent would be either covered by
medicare or private insurance
if i could senator i just want to
clarify what the numbers that i gave was
the um as i mentioned to you this
morning were the addition the additional
beds the 38 additional beds that the
dollar figure you quoted and the
percentage was based on the additional
beds being put into service the 38 beds
okay but so that's the incremental cost
my question is
because
we're talking about really the most
expensive hospital system in the state
has anyone in state government looked at
the potential impact on health insurance
premiums
for the
for the voluntary commercially
paid beds i know you haven't but do you
know
if
can we be
assured that somewhere within the
executive branch
somebody is looking at the potential
impact on health insurance i can reach
out to the insurance department and have
them do an analysis but what i do want
to stress is that
although we're adding beds in new
hampshire many of our citizens that
require this inpatient capacity are just
leaving the state to get it right now
because it's not available in new
hampshire but i will have our insurance
department look and and see if if there
will be a significant impact by adding
these beds thank you yes
are there any further questions
oh
you've had your three days no no
hospitals took us up on the 200 000
incentive payment forget exactly how
much that total but is it coming back
somehow or is it still it's it's not
spent
the 200 000 incentives payment there are
there were several hospitals that were
interested for sure there was there was
definitely many letters of interest but
kovitt hit them so hard in the last year
it is really really difficult for them
to look beyond
operating their hospitals day-to-day
rather
than taking another risk so that that
money will go back in the pot if it's
not spent thank you
okay are there any further questions
seeing none can i have a motion to
accept
fis22015
uh senator birdsall moves accepted by
senator gaida
will the clerk call the rule
roll call on zero one five
representative edwards yes clerk yes
representative erv yes
representative leicester no
senator daniels yes
senator birdson
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro
representative humberger yes
man i'm sure the vote is nine to one
the vote being nine to one
fis22015
is approved
we now move to fis22035
welcome back would you mind introducing
yourselves ex
if you would excuse me the reason i am
asking to make sure that people talk
into the microphone
is because this is going out
to anyone that happens to be looking at
our
youtube and we do have a lot of folks
that
that do that so
if you could it's helpful
thank you mary kalise deputy cfo dhhs
katya fox director division for
behavioral health thank you
okay
uh representative irf you had a couple
of questions uh thank you madam chair
and again thank you for your responses
to my questions
the only follow-up i have is will the
developed quality performance and
evaluation metrics be made publicly
available and in what time frame
absolutely we will do that we often and
thank you um for
for raising this because we often get
asked at these types of settings how are
you going to measure the effectiveness
and this was an opportunity through this
grant to be able to measure the
effectiveness of our programs so yes we
can make those publicly available i'll
have to check with my team at what point
in time that we'll we'll have that
information available um i will take
this opportunity to say that our new
hampshire rapid response program just
started on january 1st and it's served
thousands of people already through our
10 community mental health centers
and
we're watching the data
almost every day
but for the cost for really looking at
the effectiveness of it we need a longer
period of time for it to be
um
you know in implementation and full
implementation so it may take close to a
year before we're able to really take
that
step back and really see how effective
it is the other opportunity that we have
with this funding is to look at the
model we have a model and what we know
in new hampshire is
and our communities and our regions is
that not every model
fits
across the board so that's why we want
to look at these and look at the rural
areas look at what it means
for particular populations
thank you thank you madam chair
are there any further
excuse me are there any further
questions
representative edwards
this is a spirit of brainstorming
earlier we saw that 290 000 going to the
military
daycare for
alcohol avoidance i'm just curious if
if if you could
consider
maybe implementing some training at that
child care center so that the kids start
to hear it before it becomes a problem
for them i mean
be nice if we can integrate some of
these programs
absolutely it's under this effort that
wasn't contemplated but under
the bureau of drug and alcohol services
in coordination with the governor's
commission and it was referenced earlier
by chair
tufts that we have prevention efforts
and so the governor's commission has
really taken a strong look
and
heavy emphasis and
put forth proposals that look at
prevention efforts and i can follow up
on those efforts and what's happening
but child care
serving agencies are really important
thank you are there any further
questions
could i have a motion
senator d'allesandro moves the item
uh seconded by representative edwards
clerk call the rule
rule for 035 representative edwards yes
clerk vote chess
yes representation yes
senator daniels yes senator birdsall yes
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro yes
representative hamburger yes
i'm sure the vote is 10-0
fis 22035
is approved on a vote of 10 to 0.
we now turn our attention to fis-22036
good morning
good morning david weeders information
services director for dhhs
thank you very much
uh representative edwards i believe you
had uh a question or a comment uh yes
ma'am it's kind of a quick one i think
we did this offline but i want to get it
into the record
um on uh mr weeder's good seeing you
again good to see you on page two in the
first paragraph second sentence
it reads the contractor will focus on
gathering information on the data being
collected process stored and used within
the solution providing details on the
intended use of this data
and assessing the privacy controls i
think all of that's good i just think
it's missing
the plans for data retention and
the data destruction plan
so you know data has a life cycle and
and this sentence overlooked the death
of the data
certainly thank you for the question um
the intent of that was an overview
certainly in the contract it's going to
have data destruction retention and
pretty much everything that you would
expect in a data governance plan
to include how
people get access
who has access how it would be shared
with whom and for why
thank you for that i think it's
absolutely brilliant that you guys are
doing a pia on this
thank you representative edwards are
there any further questions
does that mean that representative
edwards moved the item
no not yet
no because senator daniels has a
question
just one quick question is this going to
be a competitive bid a sole source
thank you for the question this is going
to be a sole source um for
the the goal is to try to get this done
as quickly as possible to address any
privacy control issues that may or may
not be on the system we don't anticipate
any privacy control issues in the system
but we wanted to
have that report to the health and human
services oversight committee
as soon as possible rfp would delay that
process
representative keith
represented earth
thank you madam chair
and thank you for the answers to the
questions i posed i just want to confirm
that the expectation of privacy
assessment will be complete by may of
this year and will be made public
thank you for the question so the goal
is to have this if this is approved here
at fiscal committee to the next step
would be going to
governor executive council for approval
once that contract is approved it will
take six to seven weeks to complete
and then once we have that report we'll
need to
put it into a publicly accessible like
formatting in case the vendor puts it in
their letterhead or whatnot so we're
anticipating an extra week for that
um so the goal would be eight weeks
after contract execution
currently set for if we get the contract
approved in february it would be
march april in the in the middle of
april beginning of may
thank you i was actually adding up
giving a little bonus time there too i
appreciate that
are there any further questions
representative edwards
i'd like to move this item
okay thank you
senator guida seconds
will the clerk call the roll
we'll call on 036
represent edwards yes yes representative
earth yes representative
yes senator daniels yes senator birdsall
yes senator
yes
senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro
represent umberger
yes
i'm sure the vote is 10-0
the vote
on fis-22036
is 10-0 the item is approved
fis22039
i don't think you have that one here
oh you do okay i'm sorry um i did not
write down which senate okay
senator rosenwald you had some questions
i just um
was hoping to get a count
of how many households
have been
um
assisted
by this rental assistance program so far
first of all you turned yourself off
yeah okay usually red means off
sounds it's hot
okay um with regard to the uh emergency
rental assistance program i'm sorry
taylor caswell
uh executive director of gopher uh in
this role
is that what your questions i'm sorry
how many households have been assisted
so far
to date i believe we've just crossed
over 12 000 uh households
uh that have been assisted
and and just for the record also senator
that information is on our website we
keep it pretty updated there on the
emergency rental assistance program you
can search for how much is for
each individual uh component rental
assistance utility assistance you can
see all that information right there
are there any further questions
okay senator rosenwald moves to approve
seconded by senator birdsall
well the clerk please call the roll
roll call on zero three nine
representative edwards yes
clerk vote chess representative yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes senator birdsall yes
senator gaiden yes
senator rosenwald
senator sandro
representative umberger yes madam madam
chair the vote is 10-0
fis-22039 is approved on a vote of 10 to
0.
okay the next item
is uh fis2242
next one i have a zero one
okay uh
mr kane did we take uh zero four two off
we did okay so i need a motion to
approve
zero four two
thank you senator
d'alessandro
i gotta get there
okay no problem
tab six
okay
zero four two okay i'm with you okay
it was senator d'alessandro
and senator birdsall
okay roll call on zero four two
representative edwards yes kirkford
chess representative yes representative
leishman yes senator daniels yes senator
birdsall yeah senator yes
yes
senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
and i'm sure the vote is ten to zero
fis-22042
is approved on a vote of 10-0
okay we now turn
to
tab eight
tab seven i thought we had i thought we
had zero one six and ten
okay
tab eight
mr attorney general
the first item on the um
on tab 8 is fis22011
and it's a request for 2 million
zero zero one zero sorry zero zero one
excuse excuse me i
disclose yeah i guess okay and this is a
request for two
two million eight hundred fifty three
thousand
six hundred and ninety one dollars
in general litigation expenses
so
yeah would you like me to give an
overview i certainly think that's
appropriate sure i don't think anyone
here is just going to say okay here's
right two million absolutely thank you
madam chair thank you members of the
committee um attorney general john from
ella for the record
um as you'll recall we came before you
in august of last year uh for i think
approximately 2.7 million dollars for
our litigation fund that was
the best estimate we had at the time
as the item explains we've had a number
of developments that have
significantly increased our estimated
expenses through the end of this fiscal
year
one of the primary
matters that accounts for this is the
ydc criminal investigation
and also the civil side of that matter
one thing that i think has
that
hasn't been completely understood by the
public is that as part of the criminal
investigation of the youth development
center
we also have to assist the department of
health and human services with
responding to requests related to that
criminal investigation and that happens
on our on the civil side of our office
so that that has just resulted in a very
large volume of records and documents
that need to be produced and reviewed
we
we came before you and got approval for
four temporary attorneys through arpa
funds we have we've filled two of those
positions we have another person
starting in march and i do believe that
as
as those new attorneys get up to speed
and are brought on we will be able to
reduce the need for outside help in
reviewing and producing those documents
for the criminal investigation and also
reducing the need for outside help
for the for the criminal lawyers who who
have to ultimately produce these
documents to the defense
so that that
the the
sheer volume of the documents involved
is is much greater than i think we
anticipated back over the summer
so much of this investigation has really
heated up or i should say much of the
prosecution part of this matter is
really heated up since we charged 11
individuals back in april
as we've moved
i think we have a better handle now on
on what we're looking at over the next
couple years and we'll be able to
estimate this more accurately going
forward you know now that we've got
charged cases and now that those cases
are moving forward but anyway the ydc
matter is a big component of this
another big component of this is
a major transaction i think you're all
probably aware of what it is but but a
major transaction within our antitrust
bureau and it's an investigation we're
doing of the proposed combination
between dartmouth-hitchcock health and
granite one so i don't want to go i
can't go into the details of of that but
that
that is a review and investigation that
is taking
longer than we anticipated it may take
back in august i was hoping that we
would we would have it completed by the
end of the year when we came before you
in august at this point we're looking
more towards march or april and that
that will result in additional costs and
then the third major component of this
request is
a couple of federal court cases that we
provided you some detail on
that that got past the motion to dismiss
stage so in august we were still hopeful
that we would we would not have to go
past the motion to dismiss stage in
these cases
motions to dismiss in both of those
cases were denied and what that means is
we're now moving into discovery which
will require a large amount of document
review a um
some assistance from outside counsel and
how we manage that it'll require
many depositions so it's just an
additional burden on our civil
litigation unit
in addition to those three major
components what we're seeing right now
from my perspective and i've also
confirmed this with folks who have been
in the office longer we we are dealing
with a higher volume of of civil
litigation
than we have in a long time and perhaps
ever we're just in an era where states
and governments are being sued more and
more often and so
we
that that's placing a large burden on on
our civil litigation unit
i'm actively
working on and i've tasked the team with
working on strategies for how to address
this in the next budget
one of the things we've already started
to do is is obtain
things like more up-to-date e-discovery
tools to
to make our processes as efficient as
possible so that we do not need to
utilize outside counsel for help
but the reality is is that if our
lawyers are busy with a very high volume
of cases when we get these major matters
in
in order to be able to manage discovery
and keep these cases moving along and
not get ourselves into a place where we
have to
settle the cases on poor terms for the
state we need to utilize outside counsel
and that's a significant expense so
again we'll be
we'll be putting a lot of effort into
how we address that and looking for
strategies to address that in the next
budget but for purposes of sitting here
now
that that really is the major driving
force behind behind these
increased estimated costs for the rest
of the fiscal year to both prosecute
criminal matters and defend the state in
civil litigation so that that's an
overview of the request i'm happy to
answer any any specific questions you
have
are there any questions
senator guido thank you madam chair
uh general as you know this committee
has been served
and would it be safe to say that
incorporated in the cost you're asking
us to fund is potentially your reaction
to that action yes that is one of the
many cases we're working on but yes we
represent all of you and everyone else
who's been served in that case so yes
that would be accurate
the only one here is senator birdsall
has not been so yeah
excuse me
we shouldn't have fun uh
senator roosevelt thank you madam chair
um good afternoon
i know this state is prepared to go to
trial against um johnson and johnson in
a week or two
is that factored in here or is that a
separate contingency-based
piece yeah that is not factored in here
because we we signed a contingency uh
fee agreement with outside counsel long
ago and so they
they're handling all those costs and
whatever we recover in an eventual
settlement or a verdict
they will be paid with a percentage of
that
are there any further questions
okay let's divide two million dollars by
six months that's quite a bit each day
okay
could i have a motion
thank you senator gaiden
seconded by senator
birdsall
okay uh with the clerk please call the
roll we'll call on zero zero one
representative edwards yes
clerk beauchess representative yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes
senator birdsall senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald senator d'alessandro
yes
representative hamburger yes
man i'm sure the vote is 10-0 the vote
is 10-0 on fis-2200
is approved thank you
okay turning now to fis22032
department of health authorization to
transfer general funds
in the amount of
19 million
889 dollars
between various class lines
decrease federal revenues in the amount
of 83
and decrease other revenues by
19 1957
and create a new expenditure class code
so
mary kalis deputy cfo
uh dhhs you just give us a
quick overview of
why we need to do this
so periodically approximately three
times a year the department does come in
and reallocate funding
that was originally budgeted
to
address needs as they have arisen since
the budget was passed
okay are there any questions
uh representative erf
uh thank you madam chairman uh thank you
for answering questions i had previously
asked
i received a spreadsheet in the last day
or so which i'm guessing is from you
which was really helpful in
understanding the underlying
fiscal note and i know i'm unusual in
this regard but i would ask would you
might be able to provide that in the
future with the fiscal note when it
comes outside a little more time to
understand it certainly we've used the
same format for well over 10 years and
have not been asked to change it until
recently and certainly we can
make adjustments to that if it better
suits what you're looking for well thank
you for the changes those are great too
but even just having even the change
without the spreadsheet i couldn't
understand
okay but once you gave me the
spreadsheet it was made a lot more sense
so thank you very much for all the help
uh one of the things that the committee
has asked and we'll ask
not only health and human services but
all of the departments when it's time to
do transfers
that we would like to see what we call a
to and from
okay so that
we know that
it's going here and it came from here
because it's
i'm sure the information is all there
but it's difficult
because not all of us are
well aware of what's in your in your
budget although overall we know so
if uh if we could do that and i know
that
mr kane has
indicated that
he will
pass that on to das
so are there any question any further
questions yes senator edwards uh
thank you madam chair um
you know one of the reasons i've really
enjoyed working with ms rounds this past
year is that she's just a straight
shooter and so
um the question i have here
is
um
i
while i understand that there's normal
budget variances that
our budgeting knowledge isn't perfect in
reality
it's just going to happen you know um
but what i'm curious about that i
is did did we did we
learn anything in this particular round
of budget variances did we
did we miss something did we make a you
know a a significant communication error
that we're fixing i i'm just i'm i'm
looking for you know lessons learned
i would want to do a deeper analysis
to be able to respond to specifics of
that one thing that comes to mind
when we budget vacant positions they're
all budgeted at step one
one thing we found is often vacant
positions get filled at a much higher
step
which means the dollars to pay for those
positions weren't budgeted at the
appropriate level
so that's something that we could
provide data on
that might assist in terms of how we
could better budget moving forward
all right i'm i'm not looking for any
more data
but if ms rounds wanted to uh you know
inform me
if we've if she's learned anything in
this uh variance adjustment process
that's significant or material i'd i'd
appreciate just hearing that i'll speak
with you
very informal
thank you
uh are there any further questions
uh
senator d'allisandro
moves approval of
fis 22032
do i seconded by senator birdsall
roll call on zero three two
representative edwards yes
yes representative
yes representative gleasman yes
senator daniels yes
senator birdsall
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
i'm sure the vote is 10-0
fis-22
is approved on a vote of
10 to 0.
we now turn to tab 10
fis-22037
from the judicial branch and this is
authorization
to convert an existing
vacant full-time marital master position
to a full-time
judicial vacancy in the circuit court
hi
good afternoon madam chair for the
record is gordon mcdonald chief justice
with me
is susan ashley who's the deputy
administrative judge for the circuit
court
thank you uh could you just give us a
short overview of i don't think we have
any problem with uh
what's occurring but it would just be
nice for a short
discussion thank you thank you for the
opportunity you know chair
uh the circuit court was created in 2011
when it was created there were
at the number right
judges
and 13 marital masters
when the court was created the
legislature provided
that when a marital master left that
position could be converted
to a judicial officer
and as
the materials i submitted with our
letter
indicate
that has happened
eight times over the intervening period
to have that happen requires two things
one approval of the fiscal committee and
two
the fact that sufficient funds have been
appropriated
to cover the judicial officer
and in my letter i have
indicated that we have appropriated
sufficient funds for this biennium to
cover the judicial officer
we have at present
two mayoral masters
and 39 circuit judges
total of 41 judicial officers a marital
master has indicated that he is retiring
as of february 1st so that would convert
that position
to a full-time circuit judge
and how long do we anticipate until
someone might be nominated
that's a great question i defer to the
governor can't you see the second
it's uh from my perspective madam chair
as quickly as possible but i leave that
to the governor oh okay
all right
well you know um
when we when you lose a person
on the circuit court it really
uh creates a lot of problems and that's
that's one of the reasons i was asking
i agree with the chair and um it's one
of the reasons we are coming forward as
quickly as we are to get the position
converted so there's no
undue
diminishment in productivity
thank you are there any further
questions
okay uh senator
oh you had a question yes oh go ahead
i'm sorry
thank you
um i've been around long enough where i
remember the times when
uh
judiciary came to the legislature and
talked about how they needed all these
marital masters now we seem to be going
the other way
is the intent to phase out
the marital master and convert them all
back and if that is the case
then what went wrong with the previous
experiment
the this is
an entirely uh this is a policy decision
that was made by the legislature in 2011
when a marital master
left
that position
pursuant to legislation could be
converted to judicial officers so that
was the decision senator that this body
made back in 2011.
follow up
as you just stated it could be
converted but
it appears that
you choose not to
convert it
i am here asking for the current
anticipated vacancy to be converted
okay
let me see if i can rephrase my question
it's not a requirement
that you if that you change
a marital master position to a
justice position no it does not it if
i'm understanding senator your question
it doesn't happen automatically and it's
not required it is within
you know our discretion to come forward
to this committee and ask for approval
and ultimately it's a decision for the
fiscal committee
so
so why are we
asking for this conversion as opposed to
filling it some other way
there is no other way to con to fill it
okay
representative lynn you had a question
yeah if i might just add a little bit of
context to this i think i think senator
it's not because i do have some some
background in this i think
that this is really sort of a long and
uh
candidly as i think it's a story in
large part of the legislature changing
its mind
in 2011
the the idea the the statute was enacted
that permitted the change uh the
conversion to uh
from marital masters to circuit court
judges
and initially the the
and i think for that
biennium
the idea was that the that this change
would occur by attrition that when as
marital masters retired they would be
replaced by circuit court judges
subsequent to that
and and candidly in my view very
unfairly the legislature changed its
mind and decided that some marital
masters should be terminated and in fact
some were
quite unfairly in my mind
after that
at some point and i can't give you an
exam example when but certainly while i
was still still working in the judicial
branch
the legislature decided i think for
monetary reasons and i'm not i please
understand i'm not criticizing that may
have been entirely appropriate the
legislature decided well
because marital masters are paid less
maybe it does make some sense to kind of
continue with marital masters
and so for a certain period of time then
there were no changes
and
now
you know it seems that that has changed
again
my understanding and i and i asked
particularly judge ashley who's been
here for a long time my understanding is
that
from the perspective of the judicial
branch
we believed all along from the beginning
when this statute was first enacted that
it was although we certainly didn't
think anybody should be fired we thought
we agreed with the idea initially that
all this change should be by attrition
but we agreed with the idea that it was
better to have circuit court judges
rather than marital masters so it was
not
uh as far as i know it was never the
circuit court that thought
we should
kind of you know not make the
conversions but
for a period of time we didn't do it
because we understood that that's what
the legislature desired
that's if if my understanding miss
ashley uh judge ashley is anything is
wrong please correct me that is an
accurate assessment please please turn
your mic on i'm sorry
my apologies can you hear me better now
thank you
so what the legislation actually
requires is that that marital master
position shall convert to a judicial
position upon its
being vacant provided just as the chief
indicated earlier that there is
the request of the fiscal committee to
allow that conversion and then the
funding being available it doesn't
really give us the option to continue or
appoint another marital master in place
of the one who's retiring
so that's what we have to do we have to
come
and ask all of you folks for assistance
with this process in order to fill the
vacancy that we have now for the one of
the two remaining marital masters who
who have not yet retired okay thank you
very much you're welcome are there
further questions
seeing none could i oh is that a
question
senator guy thank you madam chair so
with with the addition of this circuit
court judge what will the total number
of circuit court judges be
total number of circuit court judges
will go from 39 to 40. thank you
any other questions
seeing none could i have a motion please
senator bert's all moved
oh let's let lou have it let's let
representative leishman
well you know
it's it's okay
i just need a name
will the
clerk please call the roll roll call on
zero three seven representative edwards
uh yes to approve this divorce
uh corporate chess representative irf
yes representative gleashman yes
senator daniels yes senator birdsall
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro yes representative
humberger yes
madam chair the vote is 10-0
madam chair i did if before the chief
justice leagues i just had something to
say okay
let me let me let me announce the vote
oh i'm sorry and then you can say
whatever you want
fis
is approved ten to zero
now representative leitchman you have a
comment thanks madam chair uh so i
haven't had a public ability to say this
but
until now but i work with the attorney
general now the chief justice for years
on division one in finance and i know
there was a lot of talk at the time in
question about his uh
nomination but i'd have to say that
there's nobody you know with the
integrity honesty
and
ethics
that i witnessed and i'm so glad to see
him in the position that he's in
so thank you thank you thank you very
much representative
yes very good all right thank you very
much for coming in and good luck on
finding a judge
yeah
okay
we now turn to the late item
from
health and human services
fis22043
mr kane
for those listening from home or
wherever is this item on the uh website
yes it is okay all right so if you wanna
find out what we're talking about you
can go to the website and look up
fis-22043
uh this is arpa money in the amount of
12 million
twelve thousand dollars which will be
used to pay for at home
covet test kits
okay that's what it's for
so could i have uh someone from
hhs come forward
good afternoon lori shibanet dhhs
commissioner
good afternoon jonathan ballard chief
medical officer for dhhs
uh
are there you have a question
all right two
uh go ahead sen uh representative
edwards uh thank you madam chair i i
have uh a technical question and a kind
of a strategic question to get your
thoughts um the technical question is as
i understand it
this uh 12 million dollars uh is is
coming out of federal funds
and then as we uh
sell these it look it sounds like we're
selling them um that we will have
revenue returned and it will be somehow
credited back and so
the technical question is an accounting
one
shouldn't there
as we're seeing 12 million
going out shouldn't we see the 12
million coming back in
mary police deputy cfo
the it will come back in we are still
working out the logistics with um bureau
of accounting on how we will reflect
that
so will that require another fiscal
committee vote that remains to be seen
at this time unlikely
but that remains to be seen we have not
worked out all the specifics thank you
and then the follow-up on this it's kind
of the strategic question i
i you know i i don't i don't know the
really have the feel
that you both have for
um
the sort of the rhythm of where we are
in the covit process we've had delta
which is a big one we've had omicron
which was contagious but
it
are we buying
these kits
right as the demand for the kits are
about to drop
substantially i mean the the the initial
estimate of the need was probably done a
few weeks ago when it was oh my god the
world is caving in but now that we're a
little further in the process
i'm wondering if if
if this is
too much too late
if i may representative
again my name is jonathan ballard
chief medical officer
as you're aware
nationally there's a demand for rapid
test kits it's essential to keep
businesses open children in school child
care open
the economy continuing to function in
the midst of continuous surge in the
covet 19 pandemic
the
current situation is the federal
government is buying up
large swaths of the rapid antigen test
it's been announced that they may need
500 million now additional 500 million
soon
and there's a website that's been
released where individuals can request
at this time four tests to be mailed to
their individuals
homes
much like new hampshire has already done
a couple of rounds
recently
but what has part of that national
purchase is that they are not purchasing
stock that is already
out in the market produced
they've entered into contracts with
manufacturers of rapid antigen tests for
those that have
not been promised already
what we're dealing with today is this is
really a short-term issue in that we
have large numbers of people who need
access to those tests now
and we have vendors who do have these
tests available now
but they're not into the system where
individuals can purchase them
there's limited stock in the pharmacies
and other locations and they're as
you're been aware there's
shortages where people are not able to
get them they're there on some days of
the week but not every day essentially
and so it can create a barrier for
schools to be open
barriers for children to have
access to those tests and employers so
what we intend to do with this purchase
is to go through a competitive bid
process
all those different vendors that are
approaching us and saying that they have
tests available now but they can't get
them out to the public we just want to
make sure that that access happens
and so through a competitive competitive
bid process working with department
administrative services who the team
that procures medical equipment to offer
that
procurement immediately get these into
sell
in the state
recover our cost essentially not making
looking to make any profit off of this
but ensuring access to all individuals
that's all what it is it's just ensuring
access and meeting the
an observation that we can meet the
need
okay so to follow that up uh what what i
what i think i heard you say to my
question is that this is the right
quantity
at the right time that that we
knowing what we know today
we are validating the decision that was
probably made a month or so ago
that's accurate representative
aware the department worked with our
partners at the cdc and the nih to be
the only state that dispersed an initial
round of nearly a million tests and then
we were able to do it again with another
round of of 750 000 tests that got us
through about two weeks in early
december another two weeks there in late
december
and then that this would be another
essential round of a similar size
quantity that could get us through you
know the next you know
period
senator rosenwald
thank you madam chair uh what is the
projected date for having these kits in
the stores ready for sale
so
simultaneously we did not want to slow
down and we also wanted to
to have
new hampshire have the advantage of
obtaining the tests that are out there
and the limited number that are already
produced and ready so we've been working
with department administrative services
to
open the competitive bid process it
actually closed today we're actually
able to open all the bids and find out
what
they are
we had a number i don't know which one
will be chosen it'll be competitive and
go through proper procedures but a
number of these different manufacturers
and distributors have the test in hand
and
have indicated that they would like to
ship them directly to the warehouses
and get them out into the stores as
quickly as possible
follow-up thank you does this then have
to go to the executive council
also so i'm really looking for
a date when these tests will be in the
stores so the next executive council
meeting on the 27th i believe will have
an accept and expend of these funds but
because it's going through the
competitive bid process it's not a
contract it's through actual procurement
through existing vendors
but it's the 27th it does have to go
through executive council in a different
form to to use the funding
then at that point in time the vendors
would
have the go-ahead that they would be
paid and would be able to start shipping
to the state
so seven to ten days after the executive
council
he's a doctor i'm a nurse
[Laughter]
and we're all patients
uh senator daniels you have a question
yes thank you
uh the the explanation states that the
funds
from the sales of these will then be
reallocated
to another eligible expense under the
normal process
does that normal process include coming
back
to fiscal to determine
where the 12 million will be reallocated
or are they going to be able to just
take that 12 million and put it wherever
they want without coming that speaks to
um when we get this money from the sales
it will free up the arpa dollars that
are being used to make this purchase and
that those dollars would then be
reallocated through the normal process i
understand what i'm saying i'm asking
what the normal process is i'm asking if
if then somebody can take that 12
million dollars and go and spend it
without coming back to fiscal or whether
they're going to need to come back to
fiscal and say
i believe they would need to come back
to fiscal yes okay thank
you senator d'alessandro thank you very
much madam human uh
dr ballard thank you for all of the work
that that you have done uh
i call and you pick up the phone
you do you know what an exhilarating
experience that is to have someone
actually answer the damn phone
and you do all the time and i thank you
for that because that shows we have
responsible public servants there when
we need them
and that is essential that's what makes
government work you're helping to make
government work i'm appreciative of that
truly so i want to thank you
uh and uh
thanks so thanks
i didn't get any comments with regard to
my health or anything of that nature it
was just a professional
question so thank you so much he's not
he's not acting as my doctor but he's
actually okay a state employee
thank you madam you're quite welcome
uh and representative leachman uh thank
you madam chair but when i see
alessandra's numbers show up on my phone
i usually don't answer it so
but i do have a real question
so you don't have an idea right now of
the cost associated with these kits and
what the administrative costs might be
that someone would bear if they
purchased one
thank you very much for that question uh
so the open market i think they're
around
10 to 12 per test
so that's actually the fee that
the federal government has said that
insurance should be reimbursing persons
for would be 12 per test
and so that's sort of the cost you know
if you have a box that has two tests in
it
twenty to twenty four dollars but i
guess i can say that now that the
competitive bid process is closed
i didn't want to say that in advance
obviously
and then there would be i don't know
about the actual fee for the
liquor commission to be able to to sell
the
product but somewhere on the range of
one to two dollars is what we understand
uh thank you thank you madam chair
are there any further questions senator
guidance tongue-in-cheek madam chair i
would inquire if the liquor commission
is expecting to see an increase in
revenues because they are the point of
dispensation of these tests
thank you senator we have heard that you
can get a covet test a glass of wine
certainly works for me
okay uh
are there any further questions
seeing none
could i have a motion to
move by senator d'alessandro
seconded by senator birdsall
will the clerk please call the roll
we'll call on 043 representative edwards
yes
court paul chess representative yes
representative leishman yes senator
daniels yes senator birdsall
senator gaida yes with merlot senator
rosenwald
senator d'alessandro
representative umberger uh yes
i'm sure the vote is 10-0 uh the vote on
fis-22043
is 10-0
it is approved
okay
we now move to
the
information items
and
i would
i do have a couple of comments
that i want to
pass on
um
first of all melissa rollins
is receiving a step increase she has
recently joined the lba
and
she was with
new hampshire state government before so
this was a
standard procedure just appears to be a
little early
the second thing is
d.a.s
has
provided a health insurance request or
information
and
i just felt that this was an excellent
report
and that uh your your folks that are
managing
the health benefits are obviously doing
a good job
and because
some of us remember
when
you were here
pleading for money
because the health insurance
and dental insurance were in such
terrible
state
so
thank you for getting us to the point
where
we can uh
be very pleased with what's going on
in the health insurance arena so thank
you um
we also got a report on uh
pfas
and all that other
peace stuff that goes on with that
and um i want to thank
environmental services for that
information
and it may be that i just had not been
keeping up with all the reporting but it
certainly
helped me in understanding what was
going on with the
pfas in new hampshire
fis22119
which is the operating statistics
dashboard
let me get to that one
did anyone have any questions on this
besides me
this is just a very
simple question
um
we all
obtain eye strain
from
reading
your dashboard
and it
it makes it
difficult to um
try to come to grips with
all of the hard work that you're putting
into
providing us the dashboard
and uh and we we really appreciate it
and we we appreciate the information but
it's just i don't know
i don't have any answer to it
but i just know that um
you heard
representative leitchman say that
earlier today and
i don't know i don't know how to solve
the problem well two years ago i wanted
to change the dashboard because i felt
like there was more relevant information
that i could provide the committee
rather than going back to 18 and 19
and i was asked not to change it
who asked you that fiscal
does anyone have any objection to a
uh
yeah to making changes i'll i'll
continue to provide what i have and then
when we come up with a new dashboard
i'll provide it in addition to so that
you can see
whether the new format and the new
information better suits
or is more relevant to your decision
making when i look at this dashboard and
i see
years past i just i don't know how it's
relevant
to some of the decisions you're making
and that's what makes the
the the print so small is that we go
back so far so is there a better way
to provide you this information that
makes it more relevant and useful to the
discussion and to the decisions
thank you
okay i'll work on it okay it probably
won't be ready for next month but in the
coming months
i will come with something okay thank
you very much
you've mentioned that you would like to
provide us information to help us make
our decisions the information i also get
extremely interested in is the critical
information
that's driving your decisions and your
management of the department so
if you could think of it as you know
a two-way thing because i i'd like to
have some insight into what is driving
your decision making sure and we we
talked a little bit about that this
morning um
at a pre-fiscal meeting around uh coming
with more of a strategy like a meeting
where i can
lay out the strategy let's say for
around mental health you know in all of
the projects we have coming forward now
that i could lay out more of a strategy
rather than the individual project and
although i often communicate with the
chair or or with with senator morris i
think having a a wider audience so that
you understand
my strategy or the department's decision
making is more helpful for you
great
representative earth oh it's just not
supposed to be a big discussion
this is a question go ahead
could you also provide the underlying
spreadsheets then as well
the underlying spreadsheets for
a lot of these i assume a lot of these
uh
elements of the dashboard are
spreadsheets and it should look like
spreadsheets
i think a lot of them come right from
our budget um our budget
software but yes i we're gonna we're
gonna start from scratch so i'll see
what i can provide and
we can have many iterations of it
if there's a question miss rounds can
contact me she'll know what i want okay
okay i do have just one quick question
and that is on
your caseload versus unemployment
and
i just
i can't understand
why
since um
the covid we had the large unemployment
in
april
and it's continued to go up
i know that there's supposedly a thing
that says you can't
have anybody leave
but
it just seems to me that
um
it's getting to the it's getting to the
point that uh
i i i obviously need to understand this
better that that that is
you know the the issue is that during
the federal public health emergency
you're not able to take anybody off
medicaid
so
because the public health emergency the
federal pub that the federal designation
of the public health emergency is going
on for an extended period of time we do
believe that the federal government is
going to make a
an effort to decouple those two things
so that we can start doing what we are
calling medicaid unwind which is taking
people off medicaid very quickly so the
increase that you see in medicaid and
and case loads and things like that
that's what it is um through 20 and 21.
but that's federally mandated no i got
that i guess that what um
what concerns me is that our medicaid
caseload
or the caseload has remained at about 12
for ever
and so
anyhow that's enough of that but thank
you very much for
uh for the information
and we do we we really do look at it
so
okay
um
does anyone have any questions on the uh
audit for
the
sununu youth center
okay seeing none
we have um
three audits
uh basically from the uh now don't all
of you run away
i mean
i don't know
these
yeah
these audit folks have worked very very
hard
and i know that you're all interested
especially when it comes to you
okay
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee for the record steve smith
director of audits
the first audit we'd like to present is
the turnpike six systems uh annual
financial report
um kpmg actually conducted this audit
and so with me is uh bob mahoney he was
the partner on the audit and also karen
farrell you'll remember from last friday
last week she was the manager on uh on
the term bicycle and also joining us is
marie mellon the director of finance for
d.o.t
so i'll turn it over to bob
great thanks steve um
for the record um bob mahoney um an auto
partner with kpmg
this is my first year serving as the
turnpike system audit partner
and just wanted to
indicate the materials that hopefully
you have in front of you one being a
copy of the financial statements uh
secondly a copy of the internal control
over financial reporting and compliance
report also known as the yellow book
report
and thirdly a debt compliance letter so
those those two last reports should be
separate handouts in your materials
um so i will cover the results of the
audit opinion
as well as the internal control of a
financial reporting and compliance
report and then i will turn it over to
karen farrell who was the senior manager
on the audit to cover the debt
compliance report as well as the
required communications to the committee
with respect to the
audit opinion
on the financial statements which is on
starting on page eight of the financial
statement handout
our audit opinion was unmodified uh this
year also known as a a clean opinion
so
congratulations to
marie and her team for all the hard work
that they do
to prepare for the audit and prepare
accurate financial statements
um in addition the audit opinion
indicates that management is ultimately
responsible for the accuracy of the
financial statements
and uh the auditors us are responsible
for expressing an opinion on the
financial statements in addition uh the
audit opinion indicates that we
conducted the audit in accordance with
uh u.s generally accepted auditing
standards as well as government auditing
standards
and lastly the opinion references
a separate report which is the internal
control over financial reporting and
compliance report
and in that report
you you'll notice that there were no
significant deficiencies or material
weaknesses identified during the course
of the audit of the turnpike system so
overall
the audit went well and i will turn it
over to karen to cover the debt
compliance report and the
required communications okay thanks bob
so that debt letter is just the one
single page with a signature in the
bottom and really the turnpike system
has to comply with certain provisions
and covenants in their general bond
resolutions and so what we do as part of
the audit is review those and we did not
find any compliance issues
um with the general them not complying
with the general bond resolutions so
again another favorable letter for the
turnpike system
the second thing i want to do is again
go through those required communications
very similar to what i did last week
it's just specific to the turnpike
system because we're required to do
these under aicpa auditing standards
the significant accounting policies of
the turnpike are described in note 1 of
their annual report
we did not identify any unusual
transactions throughout our audit
the management has to come up with or
make judgments over certain estimates
such as the allowance of doubtful
accounts over the toll violations and we
review these estimates and deem them to
be reasonable
in reasonable in light of the financial
statements as a whole
we did not have any disagreements with
management or any scope limitations in
completing our audit work
as far as we aware the turnpike did not
seek other auditor's opinions on the
application of generally accepted
accounting principles
we did not discuss any major issues with
management prior to our retention as
their auditors
we did receive full cooperation of the
staff and management from the turnpike
throughout the entire audit
we need to confirm that we're
independent auditors of the turnpike
system under relevant professional and
regulatory standards
and we did not identify any suspected or
actual fraud involving management or
those close to major components of
internal control
or where fraud resulted in a material
misstatement of the financial statements
and we did not identify any material
non-compliance related to laws or
regulations
finally i have to inform you of an audit
difference that we noted and this is one
that's been noted in the past few years
and that's related to the liability for
the opeb trusted plan
and that is because the state has
determined to record that liability
entirely on their books because of the
amount and not allocate the portion down
to the turnpike so if the turnpike
recorded that their oppeb liability
would be 1.2 million dollars higher
we assess that in regards to our
materiality that we calculate and
determine that it was not material that
it would affect our audit opinion on the
turnpike financial statements
so any questions we would be happy to
take those now
no i i
i thought the audit was
great
all the all the comments did you have a
question
turn your mic on
in the adam's on financial highlights
you noted that the revenues were
decreasing you didn't you didn't
you didn't in any way mention the
cancellation of the tolls that we had
eliminated tolls
i think two times and one more time this
i think january the the last told booth
was cancelled
when is that going to be considered in
the report and that loss of revenue yeah
so
is it on yes okay
so the the loss of tolls the first time
was in fiscal year 20
and then the tolls that were just
removed were in january a few weeks ago
so that'll be fiscal year 22. so in
fiscal year 21
we didn't have any toll removals that
were part of that loss of revenue
it was primarily related to coven and
the reduced traffic of the turnpike
system
one other question from
in the fact that we don't collect trolls
between 10 o'clock at night and six
o'clock in the morning what effect does
that have on people running the toolbox
well we do use all electronic tolling so
we do
take pictures of the license plate and
then
they do have seven days where they can
go into the system and pay it or we will
send a bill out after those seven days
and we send an invoice to their
presidents to collect
thank you thank you thank you
are there any other questions
okay
marie did you have anything you wanted
to see
unless you have any more questions but
really just to thank the auditors kpmg
um you know dana kaul and her team and
also
the team at term hikes and dot because
without
all of them this you know this wouldn't
be clean and when they do a really great
job so i just want to thank all those
involved
okay thank you very much
appreciate that
uh
maria i guess you can leave
unless you're interested in
[Music]
all right thank you thank you
we'll see you soon
steve which one are we doing first uh
the next one will be the lottery
commission okay
and
our office performed this audit and
joining me here is kim bisson she's the
manager
conducted the audit from our office
and joining us from the lottery
commission is linda plant
she's the ceo and then jim durris the
cfo
for any questions you may have so
so kim
am i using this one this one's on right
okay
good morning madam chair members of the
committee again for the record my name
is kimberly bisson i'm here today to
present the results of our audit of the
financial statements contained in the
lottery commission's annual
comprehensive financial report for the
fiscal year ended june 30th 2021.
the financial statements begin on page
36 of the lottery's act for
lottery management is responsible for
the preparation and fair presentation of
these financial statements in accordance
with generally accepted accounting
principles
our auditor's opinion and report can be
found on pages 19 through 21 of the
report
and as described in the opinion
paragraph on page 20 we've issued an
unmodified or clean opinion on the
lottery's
basic financial statements which also
include the notes and other
supplementary information
while our opinion speaks directly to the
basic financial statements and notes no
matters came to our attention that
caused us to believe that other
information in the financial section of
the report was inconsistent with the
basic financial statements
auditing standards require we make a
number of disclosures to you and these
disclosures were previously discussed by
kpmg so in the interest of time i will
not go through each of them individually
however we can say that we were
satisfied with the cooperation of the
lottery and the progress of the audit
and there is nothing that we need to
bring to your attention related to any
concerns with those required disclosures
also included inside the back
cover page of the report is a multi-page
letter
that presents the results of certain
agreed-upon procedures which we
performed over the lottery's operation
of its lucky for life game
all states offering the lucky for life
game are required as a condition of
participation to have similar agreed
upon procedures performed with the
results reporting to the other
participating state lotteries
in accordance with government auditing
standards we will be issuing a report on
our consideration of the lottery's
internal control over financial
reporting and on compliance and other
matters as a byproduct of our audit of
the financial statements and that report
will be included in the management
letter which will be presented to this
committee at a future meeting
this concludes my presentation i'd like
to thank lottery commission management
and their staff for their assistance
during the audit and if there are no
questions i'd like to turn the
presentation over to lottery to provide
their perspective
thank you
so what do we have from the lottery
commission
jim durris cfo for the new hampshire
lottery commission
um just
we would like to thank the you know
another three months with the
lba is always a wonderful thing
um
it was a pleasure working with them this
year and it was also a pleasure
reporting 45 million dollars additional
revenue this year
the numbers like that make it a lot more
fun to do all the work but it was a good
audit and we appreciate their help
thank you
no okay
are there any questions from
us
okay
seeing none thank you and uh keep up the
good work 45 million extra for education
is
welcome
okay
now we move to
our last audit uh also conducted by our
office is the liquor commission on their
uh
back for
and from our office jean mitchell she's
our financial audit supervisor she will
present our audit
and joining us from the commission is
chairman malika and tina demers the cfo
short enough but these chairs are very
low excuse me good mor good afternoon
madam chair members of the committee i
have got to have someone get that chair
raised because
i sat down and thought i was on the
floor
yesterday so we'll
we'll fix that
yes
that's good i like to be young so that's
a great thing so
um
members of the committee for the record
my name is gene mitchell
we are here today to report the results
of the audit of the financial statements
contained in the liquor commission's
annual comprehensive financial report
known as an aquifer for the fiscal year
ended june 30 2021.
our auditor's report in opinion dated
december 17th 2021 can be found on pages
12-14 in the financial section of the
report
as noted in the opinion paragraph on
page 13 we have issued an unmodified
opinion on the financial statements
for fiscal year 2021 the liquor
commission produced a full aquifer that
includes an introductory section a
financial section with management
discussion and analysis
financial statements notes required
supplementary information as well as a
statistical section
an important item to note no material
adjustments to the accounting records
were proposed as a result of our audit
as mentioned by kpmg during their
presentation of the turnpike system
annual report and further explained in
the handout letter
as a result of the state's decision not
to flow the new hampshire retirement
system subtrust opev expense and related
liability down to the enterprise fund
financial statements we identified a
significant but non-material uncorrected
misstatement understating the liquor
commission's op expense and related
liability by approximately 3.8 million
dollars
the auditor disclosures you have
previously heard also pertain to the
liquor commission
i will not go through them individually
but will say that there's nothing that i
need to bring to your attention
we will be issuing a report on our
consideration of the liquor commission's
internal control over financial
reporting compliance and other matters
based on our audit of the financial
statements which was performed in
accordance with government auditing
standards
and that report will be presented as
part of the management letter at a
future committee meeting
i'd like to thank the liquor commission
management and staff as well as the
state comptroller's office for their
cooperation and assistance during the
audit
and i will now turn the presentation
over to the with commission management
we'll ask go ahead mr molokai thank you
for the record madam chair joseph malika
chairman of the new hampshire liquor
commission uh we just today like to
thank jim la riviera gene and
steve wonderful job we're always
pleased to have them come look at our
organization to make sure it's running
as efficiently as it can and
i'd just like to turn it over to tina
for a couple of comments that you'd like
to make thank you
good afternoon for the record my name is
tina demers cfo for the liquor
commission
and i would just like to point out two
items on the table on page 17. you have
under the distribution um the final
transfer to the general fund was 164
million which was 5 million more than
the actual cash transfer for the fiscal
year
and this is resulting in a due to the
general fund of 5 million dollars which
we will be transferring next month
and the other is a clerical era in fy 20
column the 10 million dollars should be
in the line above under the transfer to
the alcohol abuse and prevention fund
not to the granite advantage health care
trust fund
and that's all i have thank you
okay
uh
representative edward you had a question
uh yes ma'am thank you and i'm i'm
horrible with names i'm the female
auditor um
you you mentioned that you had
one i think you said you had one
significant finding but no material
findings
uh but you had mentioned significant
material as two different things would
you would you remind me what the
distinction is between those two terms
sure if you go to our auditor's opinion
just layman's stuff is good okay um a
material material weakness would be that
during the normal course of business
there could be a material misstatement
in the financial statements that would
go undetected
um a significant difference and it's
basically based on numbers so if you
have a hundred million dollar balance
sheet for example materiality may be
five percent of assets
whereas significant difference may be a
much lower number
so it's just okay so it's quant there's
a quantitative quantitative as well as a
qualitative if there was like a fraud or
something like that thank you yeah
are there any uh representative
leitchman
uh speak into the microphone please
thank you madam chair and i guess a
question for tina if you would like take
it
uh on page 30
uh
there's a section at the bottom do uh
bonds payable maturity see that
i was just
curious the
range of interest shows from 2 to 9.5
have you folks been able to
uh negotiate any better rates or are
those pretty much locked in
those are locked in and it's done
through treasury right i didn't know if
treasury had reached out or you had
reached out to treasury to see if you
could modify them i know treasury has
made some adjustments on other bonds for
the state so i was curious oh we have
not okay
and just i guess one final question
certainly
could you speak to the debt service i
see that's
uh
pretty high 4.9 is and if you travel
down through it
uh
it's remained you know of a
fairly high lease in my opinion any real
reason for that um new building
construction i know you've put up some
new facilities is that driving that
obviously that in our new pos
system yes that's a 20 million project
okay thanks so much thanks madam chair
you don't have that in your pocket to
pay you i don't have that in my pocket
okay thank you
are there any further questions for the
liquor commission or the audit lba
all right
seeing none
i said i'd be here till one o'clock and
i missed it by four minutes so
thank you all for coming and uh thank
you for all of your work for the state
appreciate it
thank you madam chair for another
wonderful meeting
what an experience being here
you you make our day yeah
thank you
really
hey
joey
no problem